Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire,
sitting in for David today.
If you want more from me, you can find me
on YouTube on my two channels.
YouTube, dotcom slash the ring of Fire and
YouTube dotcom, fair and balanced.
I'm also on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram
at Fair and Balanced on all three accounts.
Easy enough to find, right.
Let's get right back into some of today's
top stories.
One of the ones that I definitely have to
talk about here, mostly because, look, I'm
sitting in Florida's 1st Congressional District.
My congressman is Matt Gates, one of the most
embarrassing members of Congress out there.
And Matt Gates is having a tough go of it
recently, obviously embroiled in this potential,
you know, underage sex trafficking scandal
still under investigation for that.
Now, last week, of course, and I believe Jesse
Tullamore, who is filling in for Pakman, talked
about this a little.
So I'm only going to hit on this part briefly.
But yes, last week we found out that Joel
Greenberg, the former Seminole County tax
collector, has been cooperating with federal
authorities, giving them thousands of pages.
That includes pictures.
And, of course, there are some videos mixed
in there as well.
Text messages, private conversations, all
kinds of information, some of it that does
appear to directly implicate Matt Gates in
this scandal.
So that's really bad for him.
But even that aside, let's assume for a moment
that Matt Gates wasn't under investigation
and Matt Gates was still going about doing
his Matt Gates stuff, believe it or not, here
in Florida's very red 1st Congressional District,
things are not all rosy for Matt Gates.
In fact, Republicans in this district are
growing tired of his antics.
They're getting tired of the fact that the
guy, as one Republican put it, actually Republican
who plans the primary gates says he's everywhere
but here.
Matt Gates is neglecting his district.
And one former party chair from this area.
Expressed his concern.
Saying that we need somebody that actually
cares, we need somebody that comes back, Matt
Gates has not held an event in this district
since March.
So here we are.
You know, over five months later and Matt
Gates has been out to California, he's been
in the Midwest, he's been in the Southeast
or Southwest, he's been in south Florida,
he's been everywhere.
But here, as they say, he doesn't want to
come home.
Now, don't get me wrong, Matt Gates still
enjoys a lot of support in this district,
and barring any indictments against him, he's
going to win reelection.
That is a given.
The point is there's cracks in the facade,
just a few cracks at this point.
But those cracks are growing and the Republicans
here, Republicans with a voice, are starting
to get annoyed by the fact that he is neglecting
this district we had last year, Hurricane
Sally, come through here.
Sally knocked out a bridge that was the main
artery for traffic between two cities, actually
my city right here and where my actual Ring
of fire studio is.
So we had to drive an hour out of the way
because that bridge was gone.
All of those businesses on either end of that
bridge ended up closing down, some permanently,
some temporarily.
That bridge, which was knocked out, I believe,
last September is when the storm came through,
was only reopened the last week of May of
this year.
Millions of dollars in economic revenue lost
because the bridge got knocked down.
We had Republican state leaders coming here
all the time talking about it, trying to hold
the company, Skanska, accountable because
they actually had left their barges not tied
up when the hurricane came through and those
barges or what got swept under the bridge
and knocked it down.
So those Republicans came here, acted like
they cared.
My case was nowhere to be seen, his district
was literally in crisis following a hurricane
due, didn't care, wasn't out here demanding
justice, wasn't out here trying to fight Skanska
for their neglect over there.
Nothing.
Just going on Fox News as frequently as possible,
which he's not even welcome there anymore.
Because that's what Matt Gates wants to do
and that's what people in this district need
to understand, I firmly believe that Matt
Gates's end goal is not to be president of
the United States.
Heck, it's not even to be a senator.
He doesn't care as much about political power,
what he cares about.
His fame and popularity.
That is why, obviously, earlier this year,
we had all those reports of Matt Gates reaching
out to network saying, hey, would you hire
me as a as a pundit?
Would you hire me as a talking head?
Can I have a show?
That's why two weeks ago, he launched his
new podcast, video podcast, Firebrand with
Matt Gates.
That's what the guy wants to do.
He wants this and Matt, buddy.
Let me tell you, man, if this is what you
want, resign.
Or simply don't run for reelection, just let
the clock run out and go and be the bestest
Republican talking heads you can be, get yourself
a camera.
We already know you built a studio in your
dad's house.
Use that studio, put your videos on YouTube.
I'm sure you would gain millions of subscribers
in a matter of weeks.
You'd make a ton of money having that many
people follow you.
You could sell subscriptions, you could get
advertisers.
You could do whatever the heck you wanted.
You would have more money and fame than you
could ever imagine.
And after all, isn't that what you want?
But instead, in order to get to that point,
you're taking up a congressional seat.
You're literally getting nothing done in Washington,
D.C., You're traveling the country with one
of the most despised members of Congress out
there, Marjorie Taylor Green, you're an embarrassment
to this district and to the entire state of
Florida, and you're doing it all so you can
build up your brand so that you can hopefully
sell it when you leave office.
If, of course, you're not sitting in a jail
cell by the time it all comes crashing down.
That's the problem the Mac AIDS faces, but
don't worry, folks, this district is safe
for Republicans and I think that's why they're
not putting up that much of a stink right
now.
If they thought they had a Democrat that could
come along and win this district, they would
absolutely be encouraging Gates to step down,
get replaced by a different Republican so
that they could put all their eggs in that
basket.
But they know that whatever happens to Gates,
a Republican will come behind him and win
the seat regardless or Gates himself will
continue to win it.
That's why they're not worried.